hay muchas cosas que distinguen a los
seres humanos de otras especies pero una
cosa que probablemente nos distingue
digamos a los humanos incluso de
nuestros parientes más cercanos en el
reino animal de una forma muy
significativa es la noción de que los
humanos experimentamos aprendizaje
colectivo es decir somos aprendices
colectivos muy bien somos aprendices
colectivos y para entender este concepto
pensemos como incluso nuestros parientes
más cercanos en el reino animal digamos
el chimpancé podría comunicarse así que
podríamos tener un chimpancé de verdad y
que a lo largo de su vida es capaz de
aprender un montón de experiencias muy
interesantes por ejemplo son incluso
capaces de aprender a utilizar ciertas
herramientas manipular esas herramientas
y quién sabe quizás hacer esas mismas
herramientas así que en realidad son
capaces de aprender todo este tipo de
experiencias a lo largo de su vida y lo
que es más afortunado para los
chimpancés es que pueden enseñar algunas
de estas cosas
a otros miembros del grupo por ejemplo
en particular a sus descendientes ahora
bien lo que es desafortunado para los
chimpancés es que no tienen una forma
digamos eficiente de comunicarse entre
ellos así que para los chimpancés
esencialmente la forma en la que son
capaces de enseñar esto es mostrando la
verdad no no no mostrando lo y contando
cómo hacerlo sino solo mostrando cómo
hacer las cosas cierto y debido a esto
es que la forma de comunicarse que
tienen los chimpancés es muy imprecisa e
ineficiente muy bien en realidad todo lo
que un chimpancé podría ser capaz de
acumular a lo largo de su vida no puede
transmitirlo a la siguiente generación
que podríamos por ejemplo ponerlo
digamos de esta forma en una cajita
verdad esto estas experiencias no pueden
transmitir las a la siguiente generación
o quizás a sus mismos
digamos compañeros chimpancés que se
encuentran alrededor verdad así que
realmente tenemos una pérdida de energía
tremenda y en particular todo lo que
puede ser transmitido son
movimientos específicos o lo que podría
ser observado en el presente el resto de
las cosas que quizás un chimpancé puede
aprender en realidad son formas muy
particulares de hacer las cosas por
ejemplo sostener algún objeto o quizás
torcer lo que todo ese tipo de cosas
sólo pueden ser enseñados verdad solo
puede ser mostrado no puede ser descrito
de forma muy precisa así que tenemos
toda esta pérdida de experiencia toda
esta pérdida de información pero puede
ser que a lo largo del transcurso de la
vida de estos animales puedan aprender
nuevamente la misma cantidad de
información el problema por supuesto
vendrá cuando necesiten comunicarlo
nuevamente verdad tienen exactamente el
mismo problema es muy difícil
comunicarse con esta digamos con lo que
tienen a su disposición verdad que es
justamente solo mostrando a otros
chimpancés cómo es que han hecho las
cosas de verdad y nuevamente tenemos una
pérdida de información verdad
simplemente tendremos esta ganancia de
información y lo que tenemos en este
tipo de circunstancias es que generación
tras generación
aún más bien a pesar de que hay
aprendizaje a lo largo del curso de la
vida de los chimpancés a pesar de que
pueden comunicar algo de lo que han
aprendido a otros chimpancés dicha forma
de comunicación pierde mucha información
y muchos matices que nunca van a generar
una acumulación total de conocimiento o
de sabiduría en esta población de
chimpancés ahora bien qué ocurre con los
seres humanos con los seres humanos por
otro lado tenemos algo llamado lenguaje
simbólico y voy a hablar de esto más
adelante vamos a decir que el lenguaje
humano es mucho más preciso que el de
los chimpancés muy bien y por supuesto
mucho más eficiente que solo ser capaces
de mostrar a otras personas cómo hacer
las cosas digamos imaginemos que tenemos
la necesidad de aprender cómo hacer algo
sin ser capaces de comunicarnos
verbalmente entonces sólo podríamos
fijarnos en las acciones de alguien más
verdad y así es como nos daríamos una
idea de qué tan difícil puede ser para
un chimpancé enseñarle algo
otro chimpancé pero en el caso de los
humanos tenemos esta cosa llamada del
lenguaje simbólico que es muy preciso y
es una forma muy eficiente de
comunicarnos verdad de un humano a otro
verdad de hecho podemos comunicarnos
bastante bien aunque quizás no podamos
comunicar todos los matices o todos
sobre una misma experiencia pero al
menos si podremos comunicar un muy buen
pedazo de ello verdad aquí a lo mejor no
será del mismo tamaño pero podremos
comunicar un buen pedazo de esa
experiencia o de esos matices que
queremos compartir verdad así que aquí
estamos dibujando la transmisión digamos
del conocimiento de un humano a otro
verdad y quizás no sé este puede ser sus
descendientes quizás este es otro
miembro de la tribu o del grupo o lo que
sea y lo que es todavía mejor este
humano puede venir con ciertas
innovaciones propias muy bien podría ser
que este ser humano
no se desarrolle nueva nuevo
conocimiento empieza a construir un
nuevo aprendizaje a partir de la
generación antes
verdad de lo que otros humanos le han
compartido alrededor verdad entonces son
capaces de crear sus propios matices sus
propias innovaciones por ejemplo este
también puede tener sus propios matices
sus propias innovaciones verdad y debido
a que hay un buen mecanismo de
comunicación podría ocurrir que esta
persona no sé si sea un hombre quizás
una mujer quien sea puede comunicarle
también lo que ha aprendido a esta otra
persona y puede transmitir una buena
parte de lo que ha aprendido a esta
persona un pedazo aunque sea en realidad
pueden describir exactamente cómo es que
hacen algo por ejemplo el tiempo que les
lleva a ser algo cuando algo es bueno
cuando no es bueno cuando algo es malo
como planear el futuro cuál es la
historia de este nuevo aprendizaje
verdad así que al final lo que termina
ocurriendo es que debido a que tenemos
este mecanismo de comunicación que es
fuerte que quizás debería escribirlo
este mecanismo de comunicación es un
mecanismo de comunicación que por cierto
tiene varias características en
particular
es un mecanismo de comunicación fuerte
es preciso la comunicación es precisa y
además es eficiente además es eficiente
debido a esto lo que tenemos en un grupo
humano o eventualmente en una
civilización humana es que tenemos la
capacidad de crear una memoria colectiva
muy bien esto genera una memoria
colectiva colectiva en el caso de los
chimpancés en cada generación cada
chimpancé está digamos re aprendiendo
las cosas que otros chimpancés ya habían
aprendido en generaciones anteriores no
son realmente capaces aún de seguir
progresando o construir ese aprendizaje
de forma significativa en los humanos a
medida que la información es aprendida y
la experiencia es adquirida buena parte
de ella es se puede transmitir a otros
humanos ok y esto es esto se puede ir
transmitiendo de generación en
generación así que todo esto puede ser
transmitido una buena parte es más vamos
a hacer
el dibujo de esto buena parte de esto
puede ser transmitida a las siguientes
generaciones y ni siquiera estamos
hablando aquí de expresión escrita
verdad aquí solamente estaríamos
hablando por ejemplo de expresión oral
la expresión escrita digamos ya es un
nivel superior a todo lo que estamos
mencionando por ahora verdad la
comunicación escrita nos lleva a otro
nivel pero bueno aquí esta persona que
tenemos aquí puede ser que ella viene
con sus propias innovaciones verdad
puede ser que también tenga sus propias
innovaciones y hasta cierto punto tú
podrías decir bueno si cada persona
sigue trayendo en innovaciones al grupo
y si además siguen aprendiendo lo que
los demás aprendieron en generaciones
pasadas quizás todo este aprendizaje que
tiene una persona va a sobrepasar el
digamos la cantidad de memoria que una
persona puede tener muy bien puede pasar
la cantidad de memoria y quizás esta es
una de las razones por las cuales los
humanos tienen memorias más grandes
porque hay todo este conocimiento
colecta
que digamos tienen que adquirir de
generación en generación de un humano a
otro verdad pero aún así hay límites
para esto y este es el otro elemento en
donde este aspecto colectivo de la
memoria colectiva y del aprendizaje
colectivo se vuelve realmente poderoso
una persona debido a que tiene un
mecanismo muy fuerte de comunicación no
solo está limitado al conocimiento y a
la experiencia de su propia memoria así
que digamos que este ser humano que
tenemos aquí verdad puede ser que no
tenga este este digamos este conjunto de
habilidades o de información y quizás
estas mismas habilidades pueden
transmitirse a otra persona digamos
déjenme copiar y pegar esto aunque
digamos que se transmiten a otra persona
que ahora se encuentra viviendo en el
mismo periodo de tiempo que está ahora y
que originalmente habíamos considerado y
quizás cuando el tema se vuelva
relevante cuando estas habilidades se
vuelvan relevantes pueden partir de ella
es verdad puede ser que esta persona que
tenemos aquí este aprendiz
esta habilidad o puede ser que
simplemente a partir de esa de ese
conocimiento de esas habilidades empiece
a construir herramientas o puede
construir cosas utilizando esa
información o puede utilizar ese
conocimiento simplemente sin la
necesidad de saber todo de esa
información verdad simplemente puede
usarlo como palanca verdad para producir
información y construir cosas a partir
de ello verdad así que lo que permite a
los seres humanos digamos hacer no sólo
es digamos transmitir información y
construir sobre la información de
generación en generación verdad de
humano a humano también permite a todos
los cerebros humanos digamos de forma
colectiva en algún momento del tiempo
verdad ser una memoria colectiva un
banco colectivo de memoria verdad que
puede ser utilizada para desarrollar o
innovar y para digamos ser utilizado en
ciertos dominios específicos y adaptarse
a ciertas partes específicas del
ecosistema o para enseñarse mutuamente
verdad así que de repente surge esto qué
es algo único verdad al menos hasta
donde podemos decir en el reino animal
verdad de repente no solo estamos
hablando del cerebro o la memoria de un
solo individuo verdad no solo estamos
hablando de la memoria de un solo
individuo sino que de repente generamos
un cerebro o una memoria de una
civilización entera o de un grupo entero
de una especie verdad así que solo como
un ejemplo de esto digamos hasta donde
hasta donde yo sé no hay ser humano que
sea capaz de conocer o de hacer todo lo
que cualquier otro ser humano sabe hacer
cierto
podrías imaginarme que quizás un
chimpancé pueda saber cómo hacer todas
las cosas que los demás otros que los
demás chimpancés saben hacer pero hasta
donde yo sé no hay seres humanos que por
ejemplo puedan ser luchadores pilotos
doctores gimnastas que además sean
abogados que entiendan filosofía y que
además hablen 20 lenguajes distintos
verdad hasta donde yo sé es el ser
humano no existe todavía y eso está bien
porque pueden
y basarse en las experiencias verdad en
las habilidades de otros seres humanos
para ir construyendo su civilización
ninguno de nosotros hasta donde yo sé
sabe cómo hacer todo lo que se necesita
para construir nuestra civilización pero
la información está en nuestra memoria
colectiva para poder hacerlo ahora lo
siguiente que puedes decir es bueno
hemos empezado con la premisa de que
tenemos digamos una comunicación fuerte
precisa y que además es eficiente y que
además otros animales no tienen pero no
sería posible que otros animales de
hecho también tengan algo que forme un
lenguaje así que por ejemplo digamos los
monos producen cierto tipo de chillidos
para digamos indicar que hay peligro
cierto eso hasta cierto punto es una
forma de comunicarse verdad quizás
forman un lenguaje incluso algunos
animales tú podrías decir que cantan
verdad tienen la habilidad de cantar y
quizás no sé esto significa que están
disponibles para reproducirse para
encontrar una pareja para reproducirse
la pregunta es que no forma eso
una especie de comunicación y de hecho
si lo forma verdad es una forma de
comunicarse y hasta cierto punto forma
un lenguaje pero estos en realidad no
tienen ningún rol importante en términos
de la enseñanza y el aprendizaje verdad
nunca vemos digamos a un chimpancé
haciendo chillidos sonidos de chillidos
para aprender algo cierto más bien
utilizan ese tipo de sonidos para
digamos a advertir son una especie de
advertencia en cambio lo que es
particularmente poderoso digamos en el
lenguaje humano es que contamos con un
lenguaje simbólico muy bien todo esto
forma un o más bien está apoyado en un
lenguaje simbólico simbólico y cuando
digo lenguaje simbólico en realidad lo
estoy hablando en un amplio sentido
verdad no sólo son símbolos escritos
también podríamos pensar en sonidos que
son símbolos así que remontémonos a un
tiempo en donde incluso no teníamos
ningún tipo de escritura pensemos en un
lenguaje que no sea simbólico ok así
que un lenguaje que no sea simbólico no
se podrías imaginar que tenemos un
sonido uno digamos que tenemos un sonido
uno y que ese sonido tiene algún
significado este tiene algún significado
digamos que es el significado 1 así que
no sé quizás este podría ser alguna
especie de grito o chillido y qué
significa que un depredador se aproxima
también podríamos tener un sonido 2 un
sonido 2 que también tendrá algún
significado un significado vamos a
llamarle significado 2 y este a lo mejor
podría ser alguna especie de canción
verdad que significa que te encuentras
disponible para reproducir te o
cualquier otra cosa y bueno no
necesariamente tenemos o los sonidos
podríamos tener un gesto digamos el
gesto 3 que tienen osea algún
significado significado 3 bien digamos
que tiene el significado 3 no sé quizás
este gesto significa que has encontrado
comida o algo útil para la sociedad muy
bien
ahora bien los humanos además de hacer
esto los sonidos particularmente tienen
significados verdad así que no sé
digamos que el sonido 1 vamos a ponerlo
simplemente así el sonido 1 tiene un
significado 1 significado una verdad el
sonido 2 se refiere a un significado 2 y
el sonido 3 se refiere al significado 3
muy bien pero estas son simplemente
representaciones directas lo poderoso de
los lenguajes simbólicos es que estos
símbolos orales pueden ser combinados de
acuerdo a cierto tipo de reglas o
gramáticas y para poder crear un número
infinito de significados y eso es lo que
hace realmente trascendente al lenguaje
humano y es en parte también responsable
de que este mecanismo de comunicación
sea muy robusto así que si tenemos por
ejemplo no sé la combinación digamos el
sonido 1 luego el sonido 2 y luego el
sonido 3 verdad entonces tendremos un 9
significado digamos que es el
significado 4 muy bien pero también
podríamos tener otra combinación digamos
que tenemos el sonido 3 el sonido 2 y
luego el sonido 1 y entonces este tendrá
otro significado distinto digamos el
significado 5 muy bien y así podríamos
tener decenas de millares de sonidos y
entonces tendríamos una infinidad de
significados simplemente al hacer
distintas combinaciones de todos esos
sonidos muy bien y si pensamos que a lo
mejor esto es un poquito abstracto
imaginemos que el sonido 1 es digamos el
sonido que se refiere a la palabra perro
y de hecho no lo voy a escribir porque
quiero que realmente imaginemos un mundo
antes de la comunicación escrita así que
el sonido no significará o sea el sonido
para perro el sonido 2 puede ser digamos
come y el sonido 3 es el sonido que se
refiere a humano así que literalmente el
sonido 1 si lo escuchas es perro verdad
simplemente visualiza es un perro de
alguna raza luego el sonido 2 si lo
escuchas significa
come verdades come y podrías imaginarte
algo comiéndose otra cosa de alguna
forma cierto y el sonido 3 es humano que
por supuesto debes tener una
visualización de qué es eso verdad y
esto es un lenguaje no simbólico eso
sería todo lo que puedes obtener de esos
tres sonidos pero ahora en un lenguaje
simbólico puedes combinar esas tres
simples palabras para decir por ejemplo
perro come humano verdad así que
nuevamente hemos utilizado esos tres
sonidos esos tres símbolos verdad pero
ahora se refieren a un nuevo significado
mucho más complejo que si solo se
refieren a ciertos objetos oa ciertas
acciones verdad o también podríamos
tener lo contrario verdad del sonido 32
o no sería humano come perro verdad que
quizás seguramente no es muy placentero
pero bueno supongo que si en una
situación muy desesperada le damos un
nuevo significado verdad que sale de los
mismos sonidos y eso es lo que los
lenguajes simbólicos hacen verdad además
de darte
infinito de significados que permiten
digamos darle también matices y de ahí
se pueden referir a cosas mucho más
abstractas como por ejemplo incluye no
sé muy importante los conceptos de
presente futuro y pasado verdad todo
esto nos puede generar digamos conceptos
abstractos que como hemos mencionado son
muy buenos para comunicar de forma
óptima nuestras experiencias de nuestros
aprendizajes de una entidad a otra